this is a great time to be watching
streaming movies
and you have this movie out that uh
actually sort of sounds like it lines up
a little bit
with the national mood at the moment
would you say that's fair
yes yes yeah i did this movie i'm about
this kind of young couple that moves to
the suburbs
it turns into this kind of hellscape uh
where they can't get out of this
world they try to burn their house down
it reappears
they try to drive out landing in front
of the same house
i realize now in our discussions that no
one's going to watch this movie as we
discuss it and
um you know it's like kind of gets at
the cluster phobia that we're
experiencing now
but if you want more of that the movie
is an amazing kind of fever dream of a
a movie yeah um terrible job promoting
it
by telling people that you won't want to
see it but yeah
let me help save you in your plug for
the movie
which is that uh yes if you want to feel
uh if you want to feel um
uh some sort of empathetic uh mirror of
your current situation
how about that yes uh the movie outbreak
i think right now is is huge on
streaming everyone's watching outbreak
you'd think that would be the last movie
people would watch
so this might be the perfect time for
your movie
really oh that's interesting i didn't
realize okay if that's what's popular
yes people will love this movie
if you like that other one you'll love
this
well vivarium uh is uh is one project
the other one i want to mention is
resistance
this is a movie about the famous mine
marco marceau
who i didn't realize this when he was a
young man was in the resistance fighting
the germans
in france is that right yeah he started
out as kind of like
um you know he's a young performer in
france and then he um
yeah he joined the french resistance he
ended up saving like 200 children
whose parents were killed during the war
uh and kind of developed his
mime and developed his craft as he's
doing this unbelievably heroic thing
isn't that crazy that mime was invented
fighting germany in world war ii
it makes sense in retrospect um because
it's such a powerful art um no
um well no um well
mine wasn't created i mean you know um
existed
i'm existing i'm existed but for marcel
marceau who you know i'd say
i personified what we think of as mime
in the last you know a half century um
yeah you know was
kind of perfected his craft during that
time yeah marcel marceau was to mime
what
i think i am to spoken and performed
comedy
um connection okay
how's our connection what's that how's
the connection there was a lag there
after i said what i said i didn't hear
an immediate
yes you're right uh yeah no it was the
connection yeah that was the problem
there was the connection yeah no you're
right you're totally right yeah sorry
so like here in kansas uh kansas no
you're exactly right
i would say like
was it um would you remember the joke
like uh
like you are to comedy what michael
jordan is to comedy do you remember this
yes i love is that one of the roads
yeah it would apply here but we already
made it uh listen
um did you learn any mime for this movie
yes i learned tons of mine can you show
me anything in an rv
over a uh badly connected uh zoom
session yes i mean yeah i mean wait so
okay wait this is like a thing that is
like kind of dave
this is a bit 101 this is like uh
but you know marceau would do this and
it would if it looks bad it's the
connection and not my skill set
um there's also like marceau is famous
for walking against the wind
do you know this yeah it's it's clear
show me
walking against the wind in a crowded rv
in yeah and once again
it's not the fault of me it's the fault
of the rv yeah let me see if i can
uh but i'm it
doesn't look good it's the rv the rv
look at me i'm going downstairs
yeah yeah it's a bit austin powers yeah
so i'm just leaning forward
right exactly yeah i can't even really
i apologize uh i want you to stay well
uh and i want you to make sure i get
this out uh vivarium and resistance are
both
available on video on demand in digital
right now
and uh these are great projects and you
know what it's a it's a good time it's a
good time to be streaming and watching
some great
brand new content so check that out and
uh jesse
uh yeah you're on my short list of
people i'd really love to talk to
at this moment because i admire you
you're a really good guy
and i wish you the best of luck on this
trip
get that toilet fixed in the rv and
um and and happy trails and and i will
see you in better times
thank you so much conan you too take
care jesse thank you bye-bye